virginie aurensan depuis vos mails à la
scala meneuse ceci danseurs pivot elles
sont invincibles les joueuses de
l'entente le chesnay-versailles réaliste
un début de saison parfait cinq
victoires pour 5 matches joués un règne
sans partage dû en partie aux
recrutements réalisés à l'intersaison
avec le renfort de deux joueuses
étrangères la biélorusse à l'ena
novikova et la serbe corric à piller
match mais surtout celui de virginie
aurensan arrivé tout droit de nationale
une cette saison le danger peut venir
tout autour de la raquette et leur
adaptation s'est faite le temps
d'arroser l'intégration très bien même
si on est un effectif réduit voilà de
suite des petites des petits moments un
peu informelle avec des petits apéritif
voilà des petits anniversaires fêtés
donc c'est ce qui aussi fait que le
groupe est plus soudé que qu'autres
choses je pense que ce niveau là de la
compétition c'est une très bonne bande
de copines on s'entend très bien et je
pense que c'est dû à ça les victoires du
samedi soir depuis deux saisons le
health évident manque de peu la montée
en nationale une avec ce départ idéal le
proverbe jamais deux sans trois ne doit
pas s'appliquer la saison est longue la
saison et il nous reste encore beaucoup
de matches
notre objectif cette année de jouer les
play-offs
notre objectif est la montée et
il nous reste encore beaucoup de
joueuses de l'ol cv depuis cinq ans
cécile dansèrent a pu voir la
progression du club mais le risque de se
voir trop belle peut arriver vite
surtout lorsque l'on est invaincu après
cinq journées pour l'instant on n'a pas
faim le tout c'est que ça continue parce
que bon c'est vrai qu'on a commencé par
des équipes peut-être je dirais pas plus
faible mais moins impressionnante que
que celle qu'on a justement comme le
week-end prochain donc c'est vrai que là
on va grandement qu'on entame et les
gros matches et c'est là qu'on verra si
vraiment on peut on est capable de
répondre aux premiers tests avec la
réception de glacières actuellement 3e
du championnat